good afternoon people my name is David
thorburn I'm the director of the MIT
Communications forum and a professor of
literature it's my privilege to uh
introduce today's panel uh and uh before
I do that I'd like to Simply remind
everyone in the audience that we are
embarking this semester on a very
exciting series of forums and a uh as
well as a conference in April uh the
events uh of the Forum are listed uh on
the communications Forum website uh this
is the homepage which you're looking at
now if there's anyone in the audience
who hasn't signed up at the at the uh
Communications Forum website for notices
about our events I urge you to do so
we're very we guard our email list very
jealously it is
uh I don't say it never happens but it
almost never happens that you will re
receive a message from the
communications Forum that isn't about a
Communications Forum event and there are
only a few of those so we don't clog
your mailbox the few exceptions have to
do with events that are so relevant to
our mission that we feel our audience
should be informed about them and
they're always very brief messages so
you run no risk if you sign up and
you'll have the benefit of getting
advanced notice about various uh
projects and uh events that we
sponsor I'm especially uh excited and
and uh uh curious about today's Forum
which uh seems to me to present uh a
kind of Ideal mix of of of of speakers
as you'll see and and the topic as
you'll discover if you don't already
realize it has uh has always been an
important topic uh but it's become I
think a central one for our society and
our politics in recent years I'm going
to say something very briefly about each
of the speakers and about the moderator
and then turn things over to the
moderator Professor Jen
L Joanna Blakeley sitting closest to me
on the here uh is the deputy director of
the Norman Le Center where she performs
research on Celebrity culture Global
entertainment and digital technology she
lectures on many aspects of media and
enter and the entertainment industry and
has held a range of jobs in high in in
Hightech firms in a range of high-tech
jobs including such positions as web
producing website reviewer digital
archivist research librarian she's a
universal genius it seems uh but don't
be too happy that's what they say about
Conrad's kurts as well so it's it may
not be so flatter
um in the middle David Carr who is a
columnist uh for the uh New York Times
uh writes uh his column appears every
Monday and uh is it's quite remarkable I
think what a range of materials in
recent years Carr has shown himself to
be uh competent to write about and even
a specialist in uh uh a whole range of
things having to do with popular culture
and and celebrity culture as you may
know he's been he is the carpet bagger
for the times that is to say that's his
Alias as the person who follows the
Oscars and he's he's just detoxifying I
think from that uh uh very demanding
experience and he's had this horrible
task of having to interview celebrities
for the last few weeks I feel very sorry
for him about that
um
uh car one of cars preoccupations uh is
one that I especially share and that the
Forum has looked at from time to time it
is the fate of newspapers and the
apparent uh disappearance of of of the
newspaper as a as a central force in
American society or the possible
disappearance of it or the migration of
some of our best newspapers to what we
in the long term almost certainly be an
identity only on the worldwide web uh
and this is a matter to which he's
devoted a lot of attention in his
columns and if there's an opportunity in
the question period some of you may want
to ask him about that uh David car is
also the author of a very courageous
recent Memoir that has been uh justly uh
admired by the reviewers of a book
called night of the gun a personal and
very revealing Memoir that I urge all of
you to read
Steven Dunham furthest from me teaches
history and polit and the politics of
media and culture at NYU and in recent
years his work has become among the most
often cited by students of popular and
digital culture among his books are two
especially influential titles two
influential titles Notes From The
Underground Zen and the politics of
alternative culture and most recently a
book entitled dream
reimagining Progressive politics in an
age of fantasy he writes a Blog at the
reality sandwich. comom
site finally I want to uh uh introduce
and say a few words about my friend and
colleague Henry
Jenkins when I saw him this afternoon I
hadn't seen him in about a week and uh I
I was uh the sight of him um uh filled
me with dismay and lamentation not
because there's anything about Henry
that should caused dismay but because I
realized looking at him that this was
his last semester at
MIT and uh I'm sure that there will be
many uh uh folks who share my feelings
about what a an astonishing resource for
The Institute Henry Jenkins has been but
I wanted to take this opportunity to
mention that in his 20 years here he
spent 20 years at MIT I've never seen a
faculty member in in my more than more
than 40 years in the profession
who had a larger impact on a wider range
of activities connected to his
institution than Henry Jenkins as some
of you know he's a very distinguished
scholar the author of a number of
influential and seminal books including
most recently convergence culture where
Old and New Media Collide a book that
has been influential in Hollywood as
well as among in the scholarly community
and has even affect even begun I think
to affect programming in certain ways
he is also a a teacher of immense gifts
and is one of one of one of mit's most
admired teachers he's also been a head
for a long time now been a Headmaster of
one of our uh undergraduate uh um I what
should we call them dormitories colleges
uh and uh in that capacity has affected
undergraduate life even more deeply and
fully than than a normal teacher would
do in addition to that of course he is
the genius behind the graduate program
in comparative media media studies and
probably half the people in this room
have been directly and beneficially
affected by Henry Jenkins ideas by his
generosity by his powers as a teacher
and a thinker uh I I wanted to take this
opportunity it's long we we still have
some months thank goodness before we
actually have to say farewell but I
wanted to uh uh signal my sense that
when Henry Jenkins leaves MIT a gap of
a gaping Abyss will be created that no
single Professor will ever be able to
fill Henry is currently the Peter def
Floren professor of humanities at MIT
and as you know the found most of you
know the founder and director of the
graduate program and comparative media
studies that was launched in
1999 he will leave M this summer to go
to USC and that's why Lamentations
should be modifi qualified because
clearly Henry's going to what is a very
wonderful and exciting job and I'm sure
he'll be able to continue his good work
there uh at USC he will hold a joint
appointment in the annenburg school for
communication and the school of Cinema
and in the school of Cinema Arts and he
his um um Appo uh he he he I'm looking
here to see the list the name he he he
will become what is called the provost's
professor of Comm
Communications at USC a distinguished
endowed
chair
with uh with that let me introduce Henry
and let him take over the event Henry
after an introduction like that it's a
little hard to know how to sink back
into the role of the moderator but uh
I'm delighted to to be joining you today
and I thank David for the warm
introductions to a panel and I've been
deeply looking forward to uh what I'd
ask is each of the speakers just
introduce themselves a little bit
further further and describe their
relationship to the topic and then we're
going to have a back and forth exchange
I've mapped out some questions for them
in advance which will go for we'll go
for about an hour in that mode and then
open up the floor to you guys to ask
hopefully equally smart and perceptive
questions uh we're moving toward a more
participatory culture and we welcome
your participation so that that said uh
fittingly I guess I moved from an MIT
speaker to a USC speaker and asked your
to start things off sure um I must say
we're gloating at USC to have Henry
Jenkins coming our way like who are the
fools who let this man
go we tend to cherry pick from all
around the country and around the world
and so it's one reason I'm really
excited to be there um I'm especially
excited about the center uh within which
I work it's called the Norman Lear
center it's based at the anber school
and it's very unique um it's it's an
academic unit we have academics we have
a lot of Faculty involved with us we
have students working there but we don't
teach classes we put together really
sort of entrepreneurial projects that
try to improve media improve
entertainment and sometimes use
entertainment for educational purposes
also um we're activists we're trying to
find ways in order to harness the power
of entertainment in order to do
something good for the country for the
world um we have a few projects like
that I can talk about them a little
later
but one of the things that I think we're
most famous for at the Lear Center is
our understanding our commentary our
research projects on the intersection
between politics and
entertainment um I don't think I have to
convince anybody that there's an
intersection I think some people think
it's the worst thing that's ever
happened to public discourse in Civil
Society um other people see how maybe we
can take advantage of that intersection
in one way or another regardless we have
to understand it it's it's a very
powerful sort of convergence um there's
a lot of anecdotal information about it
everywhere in every imaginable
discipline throughout the newspapers um
you know in the media but very few
people have good research on it just
exactly in what way does entertainment
affect politics in what way does a
person's political preferences for
instance affect the way they become an
audience for some sort of entertainment
content these were the kind the
questions that we were trying to answer
or at least start to address with a
survey um it's called the zogby Lear
Center politics and entertainment survey
and I have some slides and some data
that I'll share with you about that um
pretty soon okay
David um pull up your slides the uh yeah
go ahead
um David I just wanted to mention in
terms of my duty covering the Oscars and
your pity that you showed toward me
um I spent time talking to Mickey roor
and yes Kate Winslet and the kids from
Slum Dog and I don't know that it was
any more boring or less enlightening
than say your last faculty seminar it's
it's it's it's it's not terrible Duty
we're here because the ven diagram of
popular culture and political culture
has become a circle and I thought I was
watching the State of the Union the
other night and um there were
congressmen twittering the events and I
thought three things I think Congress
has been twittering a long time before
it's been a
verb um secondarily if as my congressman
I'd rather have him listening than
twittering I don't need him
annotating um what's in plain sight to
me I don't I I don't really need to see
his little thought bubbles about this
and third is everybody's watching this
is probably surprised except Henry Henry
totally saw this coming I think we saw
it in the last election uh um an
intersect let's just keep go to the next
one Henry I love that I get to order
Henry around it's the only time in my
life um one of the things that I want to
talk about is I'm going to stand up uh
because I'm self-important and because I
can't see
um what what the Obama guys worked out
is we'll give you access to our events
to our list all we want is your
information that's all we want and
that's that's a commercial imperative
over and over free is always in exchange
for your data I think of like the text
uh messaging of the vice president you
know all the mainstream media said oh
it's a complete failure we found out
what do they gather 4 million names off
that how much money do you think they
pulled lot of those people and I think
we have to acknowledge that friends is
more important than supporters if you
think of 2.5 million Facebook friends
that is a much more because of network
effects because you have a deeper
knowledge of who they are
um even the nomenclature that they
overlaid when they say my bow that
implies a kind of custody and a personal
relationship and um I think what was
what was cool is they raised more money
by an order of magnitude than ever but
then they spent it in very traditional
ways and I I don't know that it'll be
that way the next time around but you
know they spent over $250 million on
network ads so it was money harvested on
one platform was then then uh spent on
another and I think as you guys look
towards 2012 you have to look at the
Spence side the Harvest is is RIT you
want to keep
rolling we one thing I want to say about
that is if you look at they started with
the database they made it into a base
now they're at the White House they
don't just have a base they have a
database and you see the first big
hurdle that Obama comes up against if
he's having a battle with newspapers
like mine he's going to be able to go
around communicate with his guys and say
you know what they're not getting it
right you have to look and think to
yourself what was going on in ' 04 no
YouTube Facebook was just across the
street that was it no huffpo um part of
what happened and this just amazed me
was the campaign put out 70 of their
video 70 of their own videos and they
had access that we could not obtain they
did something called four days in Denver
that showed Obama warming up Obama with
the family and any network would have
killed killed killed to have that kind
of access so they have leverage that we
as covers do not the other thing I I I
think people say well you know it's on
the web unless it's you know grama
getting tasered out of a tree and
falling on a trampoline nobody's going
to watch it what was the biggest video
for the Obama campaign it was a 37
minute unannotated lecture on Race so it
depends on what you're uh talking about
one I went to both conventions 15,000
media members but you walk in to say
where the LA Times Chicago Tribune the
Tribune Co used to be no footprint at
all nothing whereas Politico had 40
people slate had 11 people uh daily cost
had had 10 people so the number of
reporters didn't change but their their
identity and approach most certainly did
one of the things that happened there
was Katie Kirk who's been in prisoned
behind an anchor desk and it's not been
doing big numbers left the anchor desk
went Guerilla with a camera adopted the
tools of the Insurgency and in in doing
so came up with great coverage
rehabilitated her career my seminal
moment at the Democratic Convention is I
was talking to Craig Newark of
Craigslist I stand there talking to him
and realized the kid just to my right
was live blogging our conversation I
thought you know what it doesn't get any
more meta than this it's Craig and I are
talking to each other and this guy's
writing about it let's see what else I
got
here do you guys know who Mayhill fer is
she more or less tilted the rank she was
a citizen journalist for the huo and she
came up with the bitter remarks that
almost
knocked uh Obama off stright and and I
saw her afterwards and I said well what
do we take away and she says there's
going to be a lot more of me in 2012
presents a kind of asymmetry that I
think campaigns are going to have to
deal with the
um the the miracle of that campaign was
just to watch an watch an organism
organize itself they created a template
and so things like phone banking which
is a goddamn nightmare for every
national campaign self-organized people
took 10 names off the list they were
able to take what they wanted and and
and and leave it there without a
significant management and oversight
from the campaign yet had a lot of
Blended media not just from CNN I was
there with a lot of video and CNN was
grabbing citizen video from wherever
they went
and one of the things that happened I
think ear early on is is it became a
kind of style thing or a an expression
of who you are and you didn't call
somebody and say we need your support we
need your vote you said hey have you
seen this video by Will I Am let me send
it to you it's out there it's ready I
think I
got
um
one thing I want to just talk about is
is is is the fact that what it meant to
be a supporter of Obama went beyond your
political identity you you you could be
a fan of Saturday Night Live which made
you a fan of uh Tina Fay who I saw last
week who looks a lot to me like Sarah
Palin and that was an expression of your
cultural identity that became part of
your political identity certain memes
would develop I mean when I was at the
convention I heard her say snow machine
you know I knew she was going to be kind
of driving her own path to the American
public in the same way and it didn't
once they created these images and I
think Henry has done wonderful work with
this way they lost custody of them so
Joel the plumber was one thing but Joel
the plumber became a million other
things mashed up and whatever way people
wanted to their own ends whatever
campaigns put out there they should know
that it's going to be used and and
annotated um do I have one more or two
more Henry can't see oh you know what
this is this is a cool this um this is a
cool quote that R Emanuel made this uh
comment about now now he's the chief of
staff but I thought it was a really
smart thing to say about how the media
is operating because I we all wandering
around the the way the conventions
historically done is all the big papers
would come in at 10:00 sort of scratch
your bellies drink some coffee and say
what are we going to
do no more for one thing we all up at 7
in the morning we are all too busy
making media to consume any media we are
running around uh um um with like a
chicken with their heads cut off and as
I watched this apparatus of Citizen
generated
content uh YouTube videos used to their
own ends mashed up I thought this is
amazing that you could make it feels
Niche but it's acting mass and what a
great te tool for marketing what a great
tool for democracy or if you're so
inclined what a great tool for fascist
as well so I do think that it's not all
gooey and and wonderful um one more and
then I'm going to sit
down you know what I'm just going to
talk about one one thing actually is is
the miracle of the uh you can lose the
slides Henry that's I was on the asella
on the way up so I was having these like
big long thoughts and I wrote long um
you had Obama girl which is one kind of
expression and then you had Derek asong
who was a hip-hop guy who got captured
making an impassion plea on behalf of
Obama in just a video that went viral
Obama girl didn't vote according to news
reports the miracle the miracle of of
and the the reason that the youth vote
made an impact is not what they did not
the activity but that they did online
it's what they did offline they went and
voted and when we look back I think it's
going to be what we're going to look at
is not how they raise the money or how'
they get so many people engaged it's how
did they take that behavior and make it
work offline and they did it by making
voting seem like something that was cool
Henry and others have pointed out I mean
I'm just coming out of the Oscars where
the polls and the participation are
endless we all you know pull up to the
American Idol with the expectation that
we're going to pay play a role and if we
just watch for sure the greatest
greatest drama in recent American
democracy we would expect at the end as
a citizenry as a culture to have an
opportunity to say I like that guy it's
just it's now baked into the process and
I I'll I'll stop talking okay Steve sure
um there's a moment uh from the recent
presidential campaign which is has
stayed with me um and I'm gonna ask
Henry to this is something I pulled off
the web so that the titles aren't mine
but I understand that because that's the
textbook Washington
gave that's how our politics has been
taught to be
played that's the lesson that she
learned when the Republicans were doing
that same things to her back in the
1990s so I understand it and when you're
running for the presidency uh then
you've got to expect it uh and you know
you just got to kind
[Applause]
[Music]
of what you got to
do
all right uh you know it was a brilliant
move uh by Barack Obama he had just
gotten beaten up um actually and this
was his comeback after um uh a bruising
debate and it was a brilliant move for a
number of reasons one is um it signaled
that he could rise above criticism and
separate himself from the Politics as
Usual and he used it as a rhetorical
strategy to do that it signified that he
understood and appreciated popular
culture particularly youth culture it's
a great moment if you get the if you see
it from a wider angle of who who stands
up first you know it's all these young
people and then the older folks okay I'm
going to stand up as well I guess this
is good I don't know what that means but
it means something um uh it also
distanced himself from his opponents on
a cultural level that is Hillary Clinton
who had held press conferences and
hearings condemning popular youth
culture like Grand Theft Auto um but
also president's past I mean think about
the use of for example rap music by um
Hillary Clinton's husband um and sister
Soldier during the campaign um that Bill
Clinton was running in which he
demonized it and it was a way to
distance himself from popular culture um
it also was brilliant because it then
got as Henry well knows it got remixed
mashed up went viral and reproduced when
I typed in for Google to pull this down
I could have picked from one of any
hundreds of different versions of this
um it also reminded us just how
unbelievably cool Barack Obama is um and
uh the moment really stayed with me um
and it also got me thinking a lot about
the relationship between politics and
popular culture and how it's shifting
and also how I think politicos which one
thing that's left out of my bio is I've
been an activist since I was 17 is how
political can start to think about
popular culture um in a productive way
traditionally there's been two ways for
um politicals to think about uh popular
culture um one is the uh the pessimistic
line and the pessimistic line whether
it's liberal or conservative goes
something like this popular culture is
at best a distraction from politics and
at worst it's a contagion to be
quarantined inoculated from media
literacy and eradicated um like the
circuses of Imperial Rome popular
culture distracts us from the sorts of
thinking and reasoning necessary of an
informed populace and a democracy um in
other words we're watching American Idol
when we should be reading Foreign
Affairs um worse the values expressed in
popular culture and for those on the
left it's materialism consumerism racism
and sexism um for the right it's
Hedonism immorality irreligiosity these
values infect the public mind making any
sort of moral political Community
impossible we're still as political
thinkers since Plato and Aristotle have
complained pop culture speaks to the
emotions the heart and the gut or maybe
a bit lower whether it be Homer or wind
instruments or rap music um whereas
politics ought to be a rational Affair
of the sober mind so that's kind of one
one approach the other approach is sort
of exact opposite which is the the
populist approach and this approach um
is the uncritical celebration of Pop
Culture as popular politics this is more
traditionally thought of in terms of
things like folk cultures uh the voice
of the people or subcultures you know
punk rock is protor revolutionary
formation which I think I argued in a
book once um but in any case this
perspective makes its way out to The
Wider world as well um for conservatives
therefore NASCAR is becomes the very
expression of certain rugged
individualism
um tied with a superior industrial can
do or for liberals I don't know
something like World music um becomes uh
a popular articulation of people's
appreciation for diversity and Global
Unity regardless of political persuasion
pop culture in
itself is a fully constituted expression
of popular will from this perspective
and at its most express it most extreme
this sort of cultural popularism
substitutes culture for politics in
other words politics kind kind of drops
off and only culture is the thing which
is examined so watching American Idol is
democracy doesn't lead to democracy
doesn't converge with democracy but
actually is a replacement for democracy
and that's something to be celebrated
but I want to offer another model um for
thinking about the relationship between
pop culture and politics and that's um
what on the asella on the way up um I
came up with mobilization but we could
probably come up with a better a better
word um and my think not yeah yeah it's
my thinking uh has been really heavy
influenced in this by two thinkers one
Antonio gromi who was an Italian
communist who died in muscan jails and
the other is steuart Hall who was a West
Indian British academic who's still
alive and well um and uh although he
recently retired from the open
University in the UK what they did was I
think really valuable I could have added
Walter Litman in there the young Walter
Litman but I'll just stick those two um
what they did is they turned their
concern away from whether or not popular
culture is political or anti-political
in itself but reframe the question what
I think is a a very useful way which is
how can be how can and how is pop
culture used politically that is how is
culture mobilized in the service of
politics now this mobilization can be
practiced in a pretty superficial level
that is Obama referencing pop culture
and a political speech um but it also
can be practiced in a much more
extensive and I think productive manner
which I'm just going to kind of throw
out some ideas now we can follow up
later if we want um because as the
populists understand popular culture
Express popular ideals desires and
dreams and sometimes nightmares and in
this way popular culture is remarkably
utopian I remember John Stewart uh
joking before Obama was our president um
he said well how do you know when the
drama you're watching is set in the
future because we have a black president
okay and so his question is what happens
if we really get a black president we be
in the future um but in any case it's
that it is what he was nailing was the
utopian element of popular culture but
as pessimists argue pop culture isn't
politics is an idealization in a fantasy
what I want to argue is it's exactly the
fantasy element of popular culture it's
sort of fantasm goric element which
makes pop culture so useful to politics
that is pop culture is a really unique
laboratory of popular fantasy that can
be explored understood mobilized and
then actualized through political
practice now this isn't easy and it's
not sort of a blanket application that
one can do because popular culture is
shot through with all sorts of
contradictory messages and desires I
mean Grand Theft Auto for example is a
misogynistic hyperv violent fantasy but
it's also a dream of autonomy and
control or celebrity media acknowledges
adulation of an AR aristocracy of the
image but it also acknowledges our
profound desire to be seen and
recognized that is not to be invisible
in our world every McDonald's
advertisement for example um wrapped up
in sort of this bad eating habits being
pushed upon us is also an image of Adil
Community line life in each case there's
a utopian element a dream of what a
better world could be then and I think
this is why pop culture at least to me
matters politically because pop culture
is this great fabulous wideopen
repository of popular fantasy and I
think it's the job of politics in a way
to actually look at these fantasies and
make them reality I'll just stop there
okay so we have some interesting opening
provocations uh I I think one place we
clearly want to start our discussion is
around the figure of Obama you two of
you have already spoken fairly
explicitly about Obama on your on David
on your slide you had the phrase Obama
as a brand and I think that might be a
productive way to think about the
campaign you know in what way was Obama
a brand and arguably he was not a
television candidate he was not a
digital candidate as a brand he's a
trans media candidate who spreads his
message across every available media
platform and I know you were focusing on
that during the campaign and wrote some
really interesting stuff about it so
yeah if if if I were a marketer I would
look
at the the sort of they began with an
ideal and just only that the substance
and and meat of who he was accreted only
very slowly and was was uh was brought
together so you had I mean you you
obviously start with um you know a lot
of people said uh Hussein Obama not the
best name to run for US president with
but that word Obama its roundness its
fullness its sort of
Distinction it it led to something
called Obama ISM where it became a
source of not just political identity
but cultural identity and so when you um
when you said you were for Obama it said
a couple things about you
I'm ready for the
future I'm ready for this time when our
we're going to have a president he's
going to happen to be black and the
other thing that's sort of said about
you is I'm down I know what this means I
know what he's talking about and I think
there's been
this given what has happened and I'm I'm
a reporter so I'm a moral and ethical
unic and have no political beliefs that
you'll ever discern but
I do think that there was a palpable
hunger among people we've seen what sort
of the Crusty old white guys could do
and I think it was yes less about race
and more about young and everything he
did where he demonstrated I mean he what
was his big concern once he won can I
keep my Blackberry can I keep it and
then when they came up with this amazing
BlackBerry Berry that that he could keep
something I think a few more than a few
of us could shamefully identify with
they asked him about he said oh yeah you
push a button on this and it turns into
an automobile and and you push a button
on this and it defends the Free World
and you go you know what I like that guy
he's funny that makes me um and what we
did what he did is he had a trade dress
as a popular culture uh figure and
admittedly you know sort of Hollywood
and will I IM and everybody gathered
around and gave him a halo effect but
he's the first guy um that um uh um
understood I mean when he was really
thinking about how can I take something
little and make it big who do he go and
see Mark andreon you know and said what
is it about you know a politicians are
all interested in that interweb you know
we got a you know let you got one guy
who can't use uh email and the other guy
who understands that it is and I Henry
has Ted the illusion of the black box
that you could just pull up to this
thing no it's he was smart enough to say
I have a very small brand it hasn't been
dented how can I make it go viral
using a con a variety of Platforms in a
convergent culture to both create
funding for further uh advertis
but also to create and and access
network effects to build my brand into
something robust and mighty that might
be leave parties a little beside the
point that might not make the New York
Times as important as they once were and
to kind of cut his own path to Brand
building so so I wanted to extend this
to Steve and think a little bit about
the the utopian side of it and I I keep
thinking about the Shephard Farley
graphic you know with hope underneath it
here in Boston Shephard Farley's doing
an exhibit to The Institute of
Contemporary Art no doubt probably
bubbled up as a result of that graphic
you know but this is the guy who was an
original gorilla graffiti guy you've
seen Andre the POS Andre the Giants got
a posi underneath the bridges but that
hope icon you know really speaks to that
role of fantasy yeah I mean there
there's two ways to read that one is the
very cynical way which is you know again
this is what Walter litman's writing
about in 1923 how politics works is you
float this sort of empty symbol um be it
patriotism or be it hope and then
everybody attaches everybody in the
populace attaches their own particular
and very heartfelt emotions to that what
might be hope for you might be different
for you might be different for you but
we can all agree on Hope um and then you
sort of trenle that out and that's the
sort of cynical manufacturer of consent
that wal lman was talking about 1923 but
I also think that yeah it does work
cynically but somehow Obama was able to
um
I don't know how to describe this but
not betray the individual interest with
his generalized hope and kind of allow
and become this almost empty this is why
the brand is actually a very good way of
describing them the sort of empty thing
of which we could all just apply what we
wanted to to him but at the same time
not come across as fake and empty and
cloying um one of the things that I
think he did really well is that he read
that there's lots of types of popular
culture out there and lots of types of
ideals out there and that the Democrats
for years and years and years have
basically read popular culture as the
way the right has wanted them to see
popular culture that is country in
western is popular rap music and
alternative music is somehow elitist um
or Urban or something of that nature um
and what was fascinating about Obama is
he just went out and said you know you
know I'm a mixed race latte sipping
Urban uh guy who likes basketball and uh
and uh hip hop and um finishes my
speeches with the big country W I know
he did well but he he's not stupid
because it is a big tent out there okay
but a lot of you know a lot of people
listen to country western also listen to
hip-hop but one of the things that's
interesting is he he was able to say
look that there's actually a sort of
competition of culture out there in a
lot of ways and you can actually align
yourself with this other thing which is
just as popular and has crossovers into
what is considered the real American
culture or you know the culture of real
American people and so on so J the
research you've been doing is all about
this competition of culture and how it
relates to political taste yes I I would
just add with the Obama discussion here
that it was very interesting to see a
certain popular Cultural Literacy play
out in the campaigns um it can be very
dangerous for political campaigns to
utilize celebrities and to engage in
popular music it's so easy to make a
misstep and Obama rarely did and uh
McCain desperately tried to actually
make Obama look bad for being so in sync
with popular culture and being so
popular right he made that uh ad that
featured Paris Hilton and it totally
ended up biting him on the ass and Paris
Hilton ended up coming up with a great
viral video that made her look a lot
smarter than anybody thought she was and
so it's it's a very is stupid but she's
really stupid it was good writing but I
heard she she memorized what she said um
it was her energy policy um but but it's
it's it's just interesting to to watch
and it was something that I was I was
looking at very closely in this campaign
because um popular culture celebrity
these things are tools their weapons
they can backfire so so did you want me
to talk about the zby Ser oh yeah oh oh
yeah I'll take this so I can see what's
up
here does this pop out just pull it
straight out
like I'll take yours I'll silence you
okay I just put I just put this slide in
here for fun you know politics popular
culture yeah okay you can move to the
next one um we did the survey uh with
zby International and uh I think it was
a really smart survey because what we
what we decided is that it doesn't
really uh do you much good to ask people
what their political ideology is you can
ask a political scientist what their
political ideology is they might be able
to have some sort of coherent response
for you but generally people just have a
lot of very deep feelings about a lot of
complicated issues but they don't
necessarily know how to articulate what
that adds up to what they are as a
political being and so we developed a
very sophisticated political typology as
part of this survey it was 42 statements
about all of the really scary issues
that you can imagine we were asking
about environmentalism abortion uh
diplomacy the wars uh military action
all the kinds of things that are hot and
but hot button issues in American
politics and we did a statistical
analysis of the way in which people
responded to uh to those questions and
we checked to see whether there were any
groups that emerged we wanted to see if
there were cohorts in America that sort
of held together by the way in which
they responded to these uh questions
these statements we didn't care what
they called themselves they could call
themselves libertarian they could say
they were registered Democrats we asked
them that stuff in another section of
the survey but we didn't care what they
said we just want to see where they
might fall on some sort of Continuum we
didn't care how many groups would come
out of it when we did the statistical
analysis the the tightest clusters were
when we had three groups the largest
group which sounded conservative to us
in terms of the way they responded to
the to these uh uh political questions
we called the red group uh the second
largest group we called called the Blue
group they they sounded very liberal in
the way they responded to these issues
and then there was a very murky middle
group as about 24% of the country this
was a national American survey 3,200 uh
surveyed um and we called them purples
because they had these sort of shared
values between the Reds and the blues it
was very hard to figure out who they
were very interesting group and then the
same set of people that we diagnosed
their uh politics we asked them hundreds
of questions about entertainment
what kind of music do you like what kind
of movies did you go see this last
summer what's your favorite TV show when
you have spare time what do you like to
do do you like to read books do you like
to surf the web what kind of game
franchises are your favorite ones lots
and lots and lots of questions like this
and also a few questions where we asked
them what they thought about the
convergence between entertainment and
politics so we found these political
clusters that were very significant this
is the red cluster and I wanted to just
get that slide up there so you could
take a look at some of the entertainment
preferences among that
group and we checked to see there was if
there were also a strong correlation
between the political groups and a
particular way of consuming
entertainment and it turned out there
was um the shocking thing is that there
were so few overlaps among the three
groups that what we were finding were
these sort of entertainment and media
ghettos uh where if you fell into the
blue group group you most likely hated
most of the entertainment preferences of
the red group and vice versa if you
liked a certain television genre best um
you most likely belonged to one group
and not another that was probably the
genre that you didn't like so it was it
was very distressing actually because
one of the main reasons I wanted to put
this survey together was to find
cultural touchstones you know
entertainment products out there that
bring people together across ideological
divides they weren't there I was shocked
um house was one of the few
cultural yeah why why equally favored
among purples Reds and blues and also
across almost every single demographic
Tab and we had just about every tab that
you can imagine race gender sex where
you live in the country what kind of
Citizen you think you are they all like
house but there were so few of those
that um it was quite distressing
actually to me but it made for good
press Rel places um I've just taken out
the portion of the data today about
entertainment preferences since we're
really talking about the relationship
between politics and entertainment and
here are a few of the red entertainment
preferences let's go to the next slide
um purples were very very interesting
these were people who actually consume a
lot more entertainment than the other
two groups they tend to watch just about
everything on Prime Time television
these are their favorite shows Law and
Order 60 Minutes in
CSI a conservative a person in the red
group wouldn't be caught dead watching
Minutes they really like reality
programming or at least they're the only
group that's willing to admit
it they love the Wii and Super Mario
Kart and Dance Dance Revolution we
thought this was really great but we had
also asked them a question about whether
they ever enjoy entertainment that was
made outside of the United States and
they said
never so it was very interesting that
there was this sort of um unwillingness
to admit or this reluctance to believe
that they could actually enjoy something
that wasn't created in their own country
um go ahead to the next
slide now Blues you'll see I have a lot
more preferences listed on this slide
and partly that's because of the
limitations of the survey um I was very
rigorous about only selecting
entertainment content that was was most
popular right the most the bestselling
game franchises the most popular shows
from the most recent neelon ratings I
could find the biggest Blockbusters I
wanted to make sure that we were asking
about the entertainment that the most
number of people had most likely seen or
heard of um it turns out that a lot of
the most popular popular culture in this
country is quite appealing to Blues reds
don't like much of it at all if if I had
been able to include in our survey
questions about Niche entertainment uh
the golf Network you know all those
places that the Republican National
Committee decided that they need to
advertise their candidates I would
probably get a lot more entertainment
preferences for Reds so this was very
revealing in and of itself that um when
we're looking at the most popular
popular culture we are looking at a
culture that is preferred by one
political group over
another okay next
slide
um this was something that Henry picked
up on in one of his blog entries on his
site and it was my favorite part of the
survey really um where I got to ask
questions about what they thought about
this convergence between entertainment
and politics how often do you find
yourself enjoying entertainment that
reflects values other than your own now
26% of Reds that's one in four of them
said they never find themselves enjoying
entertainment that doesn't reflect their
value this was on a likkered scale I
mean you didn't have to choose never and
only 9% of purples and 10% of Blues
agreed then we asked do you find
yourself entertained by things that you
believe are in bad taste 45% of Reds
almost one and two red said they never
find themselves entertained by things
that they believe are in bad taste and
only 21% of Blues and 36% of purples
agreed with with that statement that
they never find themselves entertained
by something in bad taste and this was a
really key sort of um data point because
it's not just that we're arguing that if
people like certain representations then
it's because those rep representations
reflect their politics reflect their
life reflect what they think the world
should be about not at all actually
there's an entire uh sort of audience
that that's hungry for representations
that are foreign that are unfamiliar
that are horrible that are EX examples
of what not to do and this is a very
different sort of relationship to
representations than than other groups
have next
slide we asked them whether they thought
that you could find political messages
in fictional TV shows and movies and the
full question was much more belabored it
was like setting aside news setting
aside documentaries setting aside talk
shows do you think this stuff contains
political messages and a very large
majority said
absolutely so there's not some
sensibility among the American public
that oh popular culture that's that's
that's not political no it is and the
next
one one thing that we're very curious
about at the Lear Center is whether
people learn from fictional
representations we have a huge project
it's funded by the Centers for Disease
Control to get accurate health
information into TV shows because the
CDC is found lo and behold they were
horrified to find this out people watch
prime time TV they believe it there's no
doctor on staff those facts aren't
necessarily checked so they give us
money to try to make sure to try to
pressure Kajol these television um
producers and writers to actually get it
right so here we ask how often do you
learn about political issues when you
watch fictional fictional TV shows or
films and a majority of the American
public said that they
do next one I think that might be at the
end yeah I just stuck that in for
fun okay so steveen David you've both
been paying close attention to this it's
I be curious to get your reactions to
what its implications might be for your
your approaches can I just jump in
because I'm gonna actually rip off both
of you guys before you actually say it I
want to be be to say um something that
uh David said he said earlier that
cultural identity get is becoming merged
with political identity and I think what
I love about those last sort of um
charts that you throw threw up there
Joan is I think that that's what that
speaks to it's not that people I'm
guessing that people are finding
politics in their fictional
entertainment it's what they Define as
politics is increasingly cultural that
is who loves who um what sort of things
do they enjoy in this fictional world
what sort of attitudes do they have
about their neighbors and so on and so
forth those very things which we
wouldn't necessarily have thought of
politics or if you look up politics in
the Oxford English Dictionary simply
don't include and so I think it's partly
about this expansive notion of what we
think as political is it starts to to to
to enter into the cultural
realm I do think that there is
um part of the problem that we're having
as a culture right now is our our core
expertise is
consumption and so if we don't make
stuff but we're good consuming stuff
consumption begins to be a metric on who
we are
and so you had this huge movement that
you could somehow if you went to the
better grocery store and spend more
money on you your food that was a form
of voting or political expression I
think in the same way um um if you're
willing to admit that you like watching
Tom like that you're sort of making a
statement of who you are we both
remarked when we saw a house up there on
the on the um on the blues no on the
Reds is like well what is house doing
there he's
anti-authoritarian and but you know what
when it comes to certain mapoles of
culture and this is what the
entertainment industry is looking for is
the sweet spot where everybody can find
something that they want and I think a
big part of what happened with uh with
Obama is is what you talked about what
you talked about is you had some a
vessel that got filled up with people's
aspirations and it became a cultural
marker which is I listen I watch The
Daily
Show and I like um I mean I called my
daughter early on who was uh a junior at
the uh University of Wisconsin and I
said Obama is speaking marrow what do
you think she said I think he is just
GNA kill and I said why he said the
biggest nitwit on my floor just came up
to me and said I'm really interested in
seeing this oima guy tomorrow and so
what she was
sensing is uh just as it it as as as a
handbag being a marker or consumption of
a show that this was a way to
communicate that you were with it that
you that you knew what you were doing
and I I find that you can um like the
Super Bowl I had uh 10 12 people over we
were talking about the
Oscars people identify over and over the
Oscars were such a great example of
people step and say that is the worst
most appalling thing I have ever seen
they can't get that right that's
terrible other people just going I loved
it it was Wonder careful and I do think
that we tend to use these iconic large
events as a mirror in which we see
ourselves or identify
ourselves can I raise a question yeah
sure and actually i' love because you
probably actually thought about this and
putting this together but is this a bad
thing oh is this is this a bad thing I
mean exactly what Dave is talking about
which is just sort of the conflation of
politics and culture the idea that a
politici can become a brand and sort of
an empty brand in which we find
ourselves in like we find ourselves in
I'm a Levi's wearer or what have you um
is this the absolute degradation of
politics or is it Act One view yes the
second or the second view is is this how
we've learned For Better or For Worse to
express who we are and our identities
and our pleasures and our desires and so
actually what we should be looking for
is those people that do it with
integrity that is this is the game and
are you going to do it well or are you
going to do it badly are you going to do
it with honor or not honor and stop
holding out this idea or idealized sort
of Enlightenment vision of the rational
public which is going to make you know
decisions based on cold calculation and
so on and so forth well the the risk of
uh using popular culture the risk of us
using popular culture and celebrity is
uh trivializing something that's
otherwise important right that's one
thing that gets people so up in arms and
you know they actually shout out from an
audience to say yes this is a horrible
thing um when things are trivialized
important things are trivialized that's
a huge problem when substance is somehow
uh undermined because you have added
some Glitz Factor that's a huge problem
but if you were able to suck some extra
people into the tent just because you
got Bruce Springstein to perform a song
before you spoke that's probably a good
thing so you have to mobilize this stuff
with integrity and with care and you
have to be a brand manager of sorts you
have to figure out what's going to draw
the right people in so that they will be
open and interested in my message and
your message may be a health message for
instance like what we do at the Lear
Center or it could be a a political
candidate's message it can also be you
know a proponent of evolution who's
trying to explain to um you know a very
angry audience about why it is that
Evolution ought to be taught in that
school scientists too need to use the
tricks of entertainment and popular
culture in order to get people into the
tent and to get their message heard so
it's it's often more of a method than a
content and it can be used in the in the
worst the most horrible and un
unimaginably bad ways but it can also be
used to be very effective yeah well
let's remember that it's not just a tool
of the hip young candidate what was in'
04 and and and in 2000 what was George
Bush really selling um the uh
um didn't he win those elections on
style points you can you you you you
would never look at him say Well there's
a Mensa I want him in charge of the Free
World he's got so much throbbing brain
power that you but but you say you got
John Cary with the gigantic stick up his
backside and then you got this guy who's
got his thumbs through his belt loops
who knows how to wear a pair of boots
who can push and brush around and and
it's it's like who do I want to identify
with is it um you know John Cary wearing
those bike shorts and riding the jillion
dollar bikes and butting in line or is a
guy that knows how to get on a horse and
doesn't look stupid when he do it and
you can you can laugh but I think if you
think back um to 2000 what a gas bag Al
Gore was and how full of himself that
that style that popular cultural
approach and he was dealing with memes
and and templates from an earlier era
ones that were frankly outright borrowed
from Ronald Reagan but I think worked
for him very well so it's not there's
there's a huge part of this that is not
new it's just being being it's it's it's
encountering a network effect and you
never know which way it's going because
people are up in arms with that slide of
those guys fist bumping it personally
brought me an enormous pleasure both
when they did it when I saw it on the
cover of the New Yorker you just don't
know what way things are going to cut I
want to bring it back even further um to
1933 um and you know think about FDR's
Fireside speech which is of course one
of the things that Obama's recent speech
has been compared to and here's FDR
using this new medium of radio and he is
thinking about style completely and
utterly and what's interesting about
that speech um I encourage everybody to
go and download it and listen to it is
um that he doesn't sacrifice substance
in fact he actually uses style his Rich
voice um his his uh the stuff is
actually scripted by um um playwright
Robert Sherwood um but he had um a
couple of poets working for him as well
so it's very stylized speech but he very
plainly describes how the banking system
works and so I think that often times we
start thinking about style and substance
as you either have one or the other you
either have Al Gore or you have the
empty rhetoric of uh George W bush but
actually I think that FDR did both and I
think actually that's that's what Obama
is doing as well is I think he's
actually pulling those two together and
we we don't have to sacrifice one for
the other can I can I just ask you a
brief question um nobody except
your R blue liked anything foreign but
then Slum Dog Millionaire just passed
100 million won the Academy Award and it
wasn't just one cohort that pushed head
over the top or was it you and I both
care about the Oscars so I just want to
go there for a I must say I hated Slum
Dog Millionaire I was so disappointed in
it I am the only person I know oh good
thank you thank you I love Danny Bo what
was he doing with a Sentimental schlock
I think it's the sentimentality
movie it's the genre work that's taking
place there I think that that was really
appealing to a very broad audience I
think there's so many people really do
deeply believe that there are Universal
values and that certain stories can tap
into them like Titanic for instance and
they they show you box office numbers
and say see this kind of story resonates
with people who have absolutely no
connection to that culture whatsoever
and I think it's very simplistic I it's
simplistic to claim that there must be a
universal story since people sometimes
respond to the same cultural object I
think it's much more complicated than
that but my presumption is that's what
was going on with some Doug millionaire
but still it's quite shocking that it
got the Oscar
yes well pushing in a slightly different
direction the role of comedy in the
political discourse of this year is what
probably one of the most striking
features whether we're talking on Obama
girl on YouTube or S night lives skew
of Palin or the role of Daily Show and
articulating the values of a generation
and it seems to me the discourse of of
Comedy is profoundly different as a way
of framing political debates than say
the melodramatic discourse of it's
morning in America the daisy girl you
know the sort of classic political
advertising which we might think of as
propaganda and its deep appeal to
sentimentality and emotion and this Cuts
directly to what you were just saying
about slum Dawn so what do we think is
sign what do we make of the role of
comedy in this campaign even John McCain
with a celebrity cycle was trying for a
certain snarky comedy at Obama's expense
it didn't go over very well but it was
still an attempt to translate the
campaign issues into satire rather than
into
melodrama I think that um I think that
you're right in that things have changed
a great deal because if you think back
to I don't know like 88 What was
political comedy it was uh Mike dakus in
a tank with the helmet
on um I'm sorry to keep picking on
Massachusetts people but you guys really
aren't from here either um okay sorry
represent you've got a lot to answer for
um the the thing is one of the things
that I think has happened it's a weird
like off-kilter thing funny is hard
funny is really really hard and when
you've got this
huge you you you more or less empowered
all these people cheap ubiquitous video
technology to film stuff cheap
ubiquitous stuff to manipulate what and
a lot of what Henry talked about is
you've got this
adhocracy out there working and you know
a while ago was just oh Jib Jab that's
it now you've got every kid with
photoshop with that that that can do it
and it it just gets better and better as
it goes up the pole I mean think of how
moraband Saturday Night Live was in the
culture when this election started no
one watching it and they got a puff of
oxygen off of this realized what they
had and wrote it back into the American
Consciousness so it wasn't just
politicians hitching themselves there
was only one story trust me is somebody
who writes about other things is there
really was only one story um I had I had
a book out that came out in August doing
great doing great doing great the
nominations came I didn't even care
about my book
no how could you ever in in dramatic
terms and comedic terms how could you
ever have come up with a a a a Sarah
pale and you never would would have been
able to conture her I mean and she piped
into women's magazines right away into
all all all sorts of things we hadn't
seen before and the the quality of
political humor in this uh go around
whether you're talking coar or Daily
Show or the kid in his basement I spent
a lot of the Season just laughing my ass
off it was funny but also interesting
was the type of humor which it was Sati
an irony and I think that that's
actually it's a it's a different type of
humor because it's a humor that doesn't
tell you what to think it actually is
funny because you have to fill in the
blank that is it tells you that this is
not what whoops this is not what I'm
thinking this is not what I believe and
then the audience has to figure out that
space that that that place of ah this is
what the comic really thinks this is
what I really think and there's a form
of communion there I think it's a deeply
political type of humor I mean this is
why Swift was using it in that it
actually does create a community of
meaning um because you have to kind of
both come up with the punchline which
isn't there but it also I think it's
it's a democratic form in a lot of ways
because it is about opening a space it's
not about telling you what to think it's
about leaving you space and saying okay
now fill it in and I love that sort of
style of humor and that was the
predominant style of humor during this
this this so I think that was part of
the political excitement in a lot of
ways is that the humor helped um with
the sort of the democratic feeling um of
this election right I I have a slide to
show you that's related to this we canre
you could pop it up um we get a lot of
calls at the Lear center from press who
want to talk about well we hear that
young people these days aren't aren't
reading the news and uh they're just
they're just watching John
Stewart and um so we were very
interested to find the results of this
survey uh it was a Pew research project
it wasn't done at the Lear Center and
and one thing that they do I think on an
annual basis is they do these um they
give these quizzes to people in order to
find out how much they know about
current affairs and they look at
knowledge levels and here they looked at
knowledge levels and then they asked
these same people where it was they like
to get their news and it turned out that
the people with the highest knowledge
level were the people who like to get
their news from The Daily Show and the
co bear report and one of the reasons
this makes sense is because the joke is
so not funny if you don't know what the
hell they're talking about so you have
to do your research right you have to
already read the paper already kind of
know what's going on and then you watch
the comedy show and you get the joke now
it's not to say that it necessarily
makes you a more sophisticated political
thinker in fact I'd say just among my
own sort of personal community of
friends I get a little irritated when my
friends sort of pretend like the joke
that John Stewart told last night is the
political perspective that they have as
if they came up with that critique so
it's sort of a shortcut to a
sophisticated kind of political sound
bite by sort of riffing off what smarter
people who think about this all day are
saying on your TV so it's not
necessarily um you know the most
beneficial and educational method of
teaching people about politics but
engagement is crucial there's a give and
take there's there's knowledge that's
required before the joke makes any sense
at all and so I thought this was a a
really interesting uh data set plus keep
in mind CNN's rank you know ratings with
young people went through the roof
doubled and I think it was to get in
narrative so they could yes follow the
main story but also so that when all
that data got annotated at night in in
those shows that they were in on the
joke and the ratings reflect that and
voting reflects it voting was up huge
can I can I ask the panelists including
you Henry who got addicted to Ticker on
CNN the political the political like was
updated every hour or two hours did
anybody is anybody else addicted to that
just us never mind yeah but you know
what though look at the trade dress in
that room you got John King on the giant
iPod you got the ticker underneath them
I mean but I it's just and one of the
things I think it for me it became um a
soap opera I mean and it became this
sort of Conant and my engagement was
like it was a soap oper and I got
fascinated with it I would have to
update it every 35 45 minutes the
political ticker um and I do I do Wonder
again is that engaging me or is this
turning this into a soap opera and I'm
not I I haven't figured that out
entirely well soap operas are among
among the most engaging entertainment
forms known to man definitely and it is
the best place to disseminate health
information just to let you know because
you got people five days a week they can
have very complicated diseases and you
can give them very complex advice about
it over six months period of time and
then you can administer quizzes and find
out they know more than than your doctor
friend does about chlamydia or whatever
it was so anyway um I don't think
there's a contradiction there at all by
turning politics into melodrama into
soap opera you are deeply engaging
people in a narrative and it just has so
happens that the narratives actually
happening in the real world does the
narrative then actually Le kind of jump
from the screen or from uh the living
room out into the real world oh yes we
do a lot of survey information on that
as well for our health project in
particular because we have to to keep
proving to the National Institutes of
Health and the Centers for Disease
Control that this stuff works but also
in the zogby survey we asked people okay
well what what have you ever done based
on what you've learned about politics in
some fictional show that that you
watched and it was amazing a vast
majority of the American public said
they had done something written to a
newspaper made a
donation among the poorest people were
the most likely to say they had made a
donation and African-Americans in
particular said they volunteered in
their neighborhood they called somebody
and everybody said they talked to
somebody about it you see a compelling
story you ask somebody else oh did you
see that did you
know so um it's it's I think it's
impossible to keep the entertainment
experience contained within the media it
it always ends up leaking into real
lives the last I just want to make one
point um that the thing is is content
that seems really stupid and real base
level South Park I've spent I was at
their Studios on on uh on on Tuesday and
I've been looking over the show always
topical always on the news always with
uh uh point of point of view so what
looks like some uh paper cutouts uh of
young pre-team boys shouting filth into
the air actually is keep me sort of
onbeam and in narrative yeah it's
actually that's where the form really
informs the content it's because they're
paper cut uh animations that are really
easy to put together in a week's time
that they can actually talk about the
news that happened over the last week if
they made beautiful animations they'd be
talking about the news that happened six
months ago so I'm going to open it up to
the floor for questions in just a minute
but I'm going to ask one last question
of the panelist to give you guys time to
begin to formulate your questions and
take advantage of my moderator's role to
flash a couple of Graphics of my own up
here the sort of the questions designed
to bring this up to the moment that is
last week New York Daily Post ran this
cartoon depicting U depicting the
shooting of a chimpanzee who'd Gone Wild
on its owner's home with the headline
they'll have to find someone else to
write the next stimulus bill which
forced a begrudging and some now think
really not so much an apology from the
new New York Daily Post as I was looking
to find the cartoon I looked online and
found in fact uh at least a a Year's
worth of cartoons that had directly
connected Obama to um to chimpanzees
that are part of the Photoshop culture
the participatory culture that we've
seen where average citizens are taking
images and manipulating them in in
various ways to sort of frame the issue
and then I went back even further and
discovered this which many of my liberal
friends had circulated you know we
probably have seen this on bulletin
boards and refrigerators which showed
George Bush as a chimpanzee and so I I I
throw that open to be provocative but
also to think about what do we make of
the controversy over this particular
cartoon and what does that tell us about
and what is this tell us about both the
role of satire in politics and the role
and the politics of participatory
culture I I didn't get it I did not get
the controversy so I oh I got the
controversy yeah I mean the controversy
is you can you know you can call me a
bad driver and it doesn't really matter
if you call a woman a bad driver it has
a h of connotations and restrictions and
uh and so on and so forth behind it and
so I think it was just it was this idea
that humor could somehow be outside of a
historical and political discourse while
at the same time of course um in order
for it to be funny it couldn't have been
and that's why I never bought the post
well we didn't it was just a joke and so
on so forth I think at some level they
knew and they wanted to skate that line
and see what would happen and they
wanted to be in some odd way kind of be
postracial um but also Garner the sort
of uh you know the fruits of the the
racist discourse as well so I thought it
was I could understand why people got
upset I thought it was a pretty bad
cartoon actually just well it was
executed very poorly yeah well comedy
happens within a context always and and
so that's one reason why it's it's less
okay to talk about how bad an Asian
driver is opposed to how bad a white
male driver is so there's this cultural
context and that cultural context is
completely saturated with stereotypes
and so one of the things that I was
doing after Henry said that he wanted to
talk about this cartoon is I Googled
around for you know racist cartoons
about
Obama I found several that were actually
from last year and it seemed to me that
the emphasis was really on raci racist
stereotypes that might be invoked for a
black male that suggested that a black
male was somehow superior to the rest of
the world penis size if I have to spell
it out was something that was mentioned
or gestured to in several cartoons that
I found and I thought that was very
interesting because it's one of those
examples where you're utilizing a
stereotype that's demeaning and and of
course it's reductive but utilizing it
in such a way that you're suggesting
that this person this person who is a
member of a minority and is therefore a
victim of racism and of certain
stereotypes actually has it all over us
so it's it's very interesting how these
things can be invoked and have
completely different valences positive
and negative well I I I totally agree
with what's said I think to me what was
interesting about finding the Photoshop
images including reminding myself with
the George Bush one is is that we we
operate often as with greater
participation meant more civility in
discourse more diversity in discourse it
also means that these what's taken for
Grant in the world of Photoshop collages
is probably can go much lower than would
be acceptable on the pages of a
newspaper that these C these images that
I'm showing circulate pretty freely on
YouTube and many of us were comfortable
with it on our refrigerator door when it
was about George Bush but not about
Obama so it sort of I think those of us
who are excited about participatory
dimensions of the New Media also have to
be ethically aware of the kinds of
insensitivity the kinds of you know the
the based levels of discourse that
sometimes circulate in this
participatory culture I mean that's
that's what discussion is about um in a
lot of ways and probably the best thing
that one can do is the the good thing
about the sort of the New Media as oppos
of the New York Post is the New York
Post shows up on my street and what can
I do I can write a letter to them that
may or may not be published but anything
that shows up in the web I can actually
produce something I can comment below it
I can you know try
to make my own counter one go viral and
get more hits than theirs that is is
that the Forum is fundamentally
different and so yes this might stuff
might be just as atrocious just as unil
perhaps more unil but the Forum in which
we're working in um allows for a
discussion around that as opposed to the
broadcast model those of us who work at
large media Outlets always thought of
the web as one more publishing
opportunity when in fact Jeff Jarvis and
others remind us it's actually a way for
you to listen and here and I gr that I
thought that's great and then I started
to occasionally Veer into political
issues and the level of discourse I mean
historically it's always assumed that
the people on the right weaned on talk
radio mouth breathers that they are are
the foulest most that that they'll come
at you with all man I noticed no
difference in level of discourse
according to political opinion and the
rawness of it that's disrespectful of us
of it and I'm not even a woman because
at our paper if you're a woman it would
always start with your physique it would
always start with your body parts and
before they even got to and and so it's
it's great that we can hear from our our
audience it's sometimes appalling what
they really want to talk
[Laughter]
about okay on that note we'll he what
our really wants to talk about so
prepare to be appalled uh I had one
thing if you don't mind um uh a friend
sent this to me and I just found it so
deeply compelling and I think it fits in
very nicely with with your book your
book project and what you're saying
about dreams and politics and and really
engaging with political discourse in
popular culture having uh uh writing
blogs about it making videos and remix
videos and stuff it's a way of um of
creating a story where you have a role
in it right and it's participatory well
one thing I was fascinated by was this
blog blog entry on the New York Times
site it was about it was called dreams
of Obama did you see that and it was the
Blogger I can't remember who it was said
that her friends started mentioning to
her that I've been dreaming about
Obama and I like Michelle but now I feel
kind of
guilty so so people have been and so she
started collecting all these dreams
about Obama and the oh the dreams were
so fascinating sometimes they were
sexual sometimes they were fraught with
all this angst because I really like
Michelle why am I doing this to her but
sometimes it was Obama's taking out my
trash and he's cleaning up my house I
think it's
metaphorical and then you you know you
post this online and becomes a part of a
sort of political Consciousness that
that's deeply subconscious and it's
great storytelling and it's it's really
deeply affecting the lives that we're
leading so I just want to throw that one
out there okay so over here first um in
in term I'm in sympathy with with some
of what I think was being said about
brand Obama and sort of you know reading
anything in into it you want to um the
things that were in a way most
impressive to me about Obama as a
candidate as a as a uh presented uh
candidate uh were in broadcast
television and there are two moments
that I want to mention uh one was in one
of the debates where he was being
attacked by Hillary and what
I saw on the screen I I thought was
someone taking in the attack sort of
watching him process this attack in a
kind of and his What Might Have Been
a an inclination to lash back but sort
of processing it controlling it and then
responding from another place and I was
impressed with that whether I like Obama
politically or or not and I'm not that
that impressed with Obama in some ways
the other moment was when what I took to
be a sort of feigned gesture at the end
of a subsequent debate I think it was
when he got up and kind of went to pull
to show that he was interested in
pulling Hillary's chair away from her at
the end of the debate to sort of hold
her chair for her and what I part of
what I wonder is is the first instance
possibly does any of you think it's an
example of someone with their
Consultants understanding the nature of
television as a medium
and understanding the importance the
need to be present a cool kind of uh uh
presentation and whatever you might have
to say about the other example and also
I'm not sure I quite understand how you
can manipulate or and I know this was
just a offthe cuff use of a word trick
people with Integrity it seems to me you
know you might have a good message you
might want to draw people in to hear a
good message I was sort of in sympathy
with bringing up the example of bush um
but I just don't understand how
manipulating people is is something
that's done with any kind of Integrity
even if your message you might think is
a good one yeah I I just want to speak
to that quickly um two things one is I
actually think that don't underestimate
Obama's training since you the age of
one in um being surveyed and looked at
he's a black man growing up and uh you
know a non-black country and that when
he walks into a room people look at him
and have judgments about him and he's
learned to look at himself I mean this
is what Deo writes about with double
Consciousness and so I think that that
studied cool that people saw had a lot
to do with growing up black in America
um and it can go one way or the other
and this is the way it went with him um
but going back to the idea of
manipulation and how do you have
integrity within manipulation I'll give
you one example um which is Las Vegas um
not the gambling casinos um but that Las
Vegas is a fake and everybody knows it's
a fake that is it manipulates you uh or
rather it is a spectacle it is attracts
you it draws you in but no one who goes
to New York New York in Las Vegas thinks
they're actually going to New York um
that is is that you can have a sort of a
spectacular um uh portrayal you can have
a stylistic portrayal but all at the
same time be very open about what you're
doing and this is the difference between
something like George Bush landing on
the USSA Abraham Lincoln which is
selling a fantasy as the truth um versus
presenting a good story um and
presenting a uh a narrative or a brand
that people actually want to be part of
we're not saying that he's actually fake
um we're saying he's learned how to
package himself sell himself and be an
identity and to be an image in a lot of
ways and I think to a certain extent we
we all do that now and he's just
particularly good at it I I think it's
just a splendid question because
when I I remember the first instance
you're talking about and when he was
processing was he also processing what
you and I would
think doing they think that I think that
she thinks that what was he because it's
it's I've seen the guy up close and it's
hard to sort
of overestimate the amount of processing
power at work there is is and I think a
lot of it comes from what what what
Steve was talking about
and also an awareness going forward that
at some point this is going to be played
out in a public context the other thing
and this
is less to that point but these
exemplars over and over the ability of
time and platform shift so if you came
in on Monday and I worked with you and
you said did you see Obama really
thinking it through before he and I
would say no but I'm going to go look at
it right now
and I think that's something completely
different was the ability to catch up
time and again get narrative the water
cooler was this movable time and
platform shifted thing where we could
all be in on the joke we could all be in
on and it gave us an opportunity to have
I think a deeper conversation along the
way okay question over here hi I'm Ian
condre and I teach in comparative media
studies um very interesting really
wonderful discussion a lot levels uh one
of the things I wanted to uh push on was
the image of popular culture you know
what is this popular culture and one of
the things I I've been getting from the
discussion is that a lot of it seems to
be about representations or a way of
thinking about individuals either As
Leaders who are branded in certain ways
as chimps or as cool rap ficient AOS um
or in terms of the kind of
individualized consumer right the the
red groups the red consumers the blue
consumers the purple consumers as a kind
of large mass I guess basically and I
think one of the things that I found so
interesting about the Obama phenomenon
is that it started to draw attention to
this middle level of politics where it
was more about small groups networking
right a kind of collective
engagement uh that was less about the
representations as it was about
facilitating the flow that then got
people to feel involved and got people
in in kind of small groups uh I think it
it's a kind of jazz democracy right you
have these people improvising on
different themes but in small groups um
and so you know and some of the things
you know the the uh you know this
distinction between you know news what
happens in documentaries and talk shows
and then that's not pop culture and the
other stuff is I'm not sure about those
kind of distinctions because if pop
culture is the things that we talk about
and that if we watch Cole bear with the
knowledge of what really happens in the
news then that distinction doesn't
really hold and and why it doesn't hold
is because it's about how we talk about
it with each other and that there it
doesn't matter whether we learned it
from Co bear or we learned it from a
column in the New York Times and and so
I think you know that that I guess
that's the the level I I'm sort of
curious uh to hear more about and that's
the the conversation you know the word
mobilization came up and I think maybe
mobilize is is one way to think about it
um right Collective engagement uh and
that the there is this kind of middle
level of politics I mean it's the thing
that's been so frustrating about the
whole meltdown is that it's either we
need great leaders to somehow pull us
out of this or we should just keep
spending you know as consumers and it
seems to me it's this middle level what
are corporations how do they work you
know what are what are our
responsibilities as as a nation of
consumers or as people who live in
certain ways how do we participate in
these smaller groups uh that really
seems what to be what Obama suggested or
showed was out there but it seems we
still have our discourse still hasn't
caught up uh to find out a way to talk
about that thank
you
no okay
David I thought this is perfect for
you he said mobilization so it's on you
my brother but it ended on okay I would
agree if we weren't talking about
popular culture say one of the things
that I as a political activist really
admired about the Obama campaign was
that they were able through their
networking to reactivate sort of Civic
society and civil society and so you
could actually this is you know you
could actually plug in at all sorts of
levels and be an activist for a day and
one of the things I learned as a
community organizers the first thing you
do when someone comes to a meeting is
you give them a job because once they
actually complete that task no matter
how small it is they are now part of
your campaign and so one of the things
they did was build to you know to expand
the term a culture of organizing and and
one of the things that people have been
talking about in my circle of political
organizers is what do we do with this
culture of organizing now is Obama going
to use it or have all these people that
used to think of themselves as consumers
of politics now think of themselves as
producers of politics how can we tap
into that because that's when social
movements and organizations explode when
people who don't think of themselves as
political start to actually act as
political because they bring in all of
this new stuff you saw in the civil
movement you start during act up and
that's when these things explode into
all sorts of new and exciting formations
which US tired old political would have
never thought of that's what I thought
you were going to talk about and I read
some article that that you wrote
recently about how powerful these small
networks are in particular because it's
a way in which groups of people can sort
of can sort of share a sense of being
celebrities right they become known to
other people right we always think of it
as a mass audience and one celebrity and
everybody's looking for their seven
minutes of fame or the seven seconds of
Fame but when you have these really
tight aggressive and uh and mobilized
little networks everybody becomes a kind
of celebrity within them and so I think
that's another way in which popular
culture and this whole notion of
celebrity becomes injected into
participatory culture and into the
political process in in I think a very
functional fashion yeah the the the
ability to C cized
by geography among other things I think
LED itself to a really
substantial online offline response part
of what people need to know this isn't
some crunchy Progressive imperative
people look at a mega church in Houston
and say how can the needs the spiritual
needs of 4800 people be satisfied by
this one guy a of course not they've
self assigned into prayer groups they
meet where there there there are subers
and that they they are um and everybody
gets a role to play and the amount of
sort of feedback about not only do you
exist but you are a good person you're
trying you're you're you're involved on
a very retail level and I mean Obama has
always said is the Chicago in him but
I've watched him work a room of really
drunk entitled white people and and and
and watched him work the retail aspect
of it and I do think that he came up
with a campaign organism that replicated
the ability to not just suck things from
people but to give them things as well
to give them a psychic return for
involvement one of the things that I
argue in convergence culture is we've
been you learning through our play
skills we're going to acquire we're
going to apply to more serious purposes
as we find the cause that drives us so I
think one I would argue that pop culture
consumption today is almost never
individual it's always social it's
always being through networks in one way
or another that fan communities and
gamer communities have more and more
become large scale collective bargaining
units on behalf of media consumers and
as they do so they're teaching their
Rank and file how to act politically and
so I'm very interested in sort of protop
political behaviors like now
so how do people quickly mobilize to
write letters to keep a television show
on the air or to repel a cease and the
cyst letter that's thrown out them and
how do we move from those tactics into
new forms of political activism and I
suggested most of what I saw in the
Obama campaign I recognized from fan
cultures of one sort or another the myth
of Obama as fan and chief is running
through the communities I regularly
study uh the fact that he reads Harry
Potter novels to his kids that he can
reference you YouTube videos that he
knows how to do the Vulcan salute
there's a whole mythology about Obama as
geek fan booy right yes there is that
has taken root in the society which made
him an appealing candidate for the shock
troops who've been learning how to
navigate through social networks to
achieve protop political ends which now
are becoming political as they as their
tension turns from the cultural sphere
toward more traditional politics and the
activ activation of those various
various verticals of Interest it often
involves you know somebody blew a
whistle none of the rest of us could
hear but he is a whistleblower in Chief
he's somebody who can make a noise that
that various verticals and and he's he's
he's able to sort of customize and
segment his message and send it out you
know radi a message to where PE a lot of
people feel he belongs to them and
they're all very different people and
what's different I think is is that
we're used to thinking of consuming as
this sort of passive activity and then
of course there's this you know moment
where people started say well it's not
necessarily passive because we bestow
meanings on what we consume and so on
and so forth but now because of
Technology particularly in the media
sphere we're rarely just consumers we're
actually consumer producers all the time
um and what I think that that Obama
tapped into is not just sort of age-old
organizing techniques which he would
have learned in the streets of Chicago
as a community organizer but also this
fundamental understanding that when
people consume message they want to
produce it as well they want to make it
go viral they want to put their own
little spin on it um yeah they called it
snowflake organizing within their world
which every snowflake was different so
you would take in Obama's message and
then you'd reproduce it but they allowed
for a lot of sort of um how do I want to
say this uh they allowed people to to
make it their own um and they never did
the clamping down and policing on the
videos not that they could have um and
on the message not that they could have
but they didn't even try they realized
you know the thousand flowers bloom is
going to work for us as long as we got
that 30- minute infomercial and I mean
Henry and others have written about what
customization will do the ability to
just put a little Top Spin on just to
touch it get it mov in a certain way
okay over here thank you um I'm not
quite sure Henry what New Media you used
to discern uh what the question was that
I was going to ask but thank you for
laying the groundwork for it um I'd like
to change the perspective a little bit
if pop culture is uh ephemeral and
fleeting if
we've uh enjoyed you know discussing the
success of the new media and politics
let's go four years in the future will
there be a Twitter will there be a
Facebook what's in the pipelines now
that are going to substantially change
the Paradigm for
2012 hry
yeah my crystal ball they issued when I
became an MIT faculty member is busted
this week uh you know I think the
interesting thing is I I would I wrote
completed convergence culture when the
last campaign was ending convergence
culture doesn't include any reference to
Web 2.0 doesn't include any reference to
YouTube doesn't include any reference to
Second Life doesn't include any
reference to Twitter has a passing
efference added the very last minute to
iTunes so all of that has happened since
the last presidential election and I'm
modest enough to admit to you that I
didn't see most of that coming the logic
of what what that book described would
account for all of that the specifics
are all you know we're on the horizon
but we don't know yet what they're going
to be so I think we can think logically
where the culture is going to move us
but I think it's none of us could tell
you what the Technologies for years from
now or the platforms for years from now
are actually going to be that enable
that polic politics that take place but
if you looked four years ago you would
have seen the beginnings of satire as a
political tool you would have seen signs
of fan-based movements and politics you
would have seen a number of the things
we talked about here today the lessons
of Joe trippy and howardan impacted
Obama in ways that you know we could
have predicted but we can't what we
can't predict is what's the platform I
think I don't think you can overestimate
how radical it could be if you look at
this slide I had no Facebook no you know
what I mean how rapidly things could
change you could have a candidate in 02
say yeah I got a media strategy let's
not engage them at
all
zero we're going to broadcast out we
using our own media and we're we're
we're going to build constituency and we
don't want third- party annotation of
anything we do could be as radical as
that yeah uh David put up fleeting
reference to Walter Benjamin up there
and you know Walter Benjamin seminal
article on um art and the AG of
mechanical reproduction it ends in this
conclusion which says essentially
reproduction has changed the ball game
for politics and it's either going to
lead to Fascism or it's going to lead to
a democratic communism and he's holding
it open because he doesn't know which
way it's going to go either the idea the
image is going to become reor fied re
together and given a singular meaning
under fascism or people are going to
have a discussion about the meaning of
images and so on and so forth and I
think that's exactly way we have to look
at it now is you can look at the logic
of what's happening but also understand
that there's always agency there that it
can split one way or split the other
way okay over
here hi thanks for a great panel uh my
name is meline I'm a graduate student in
the comparative media studies Department
I have a question I guess joina mainly
for you but also expand it outward
um what role does age play in the the
sort of preferences the sort
of Def definitions of each of those
groups because it seemed to me that
their you know age would be a factor and
sort of expand it out what role does
does age play in the formation of
popular culture is it really driven by
the sort of younger half of people or um
also other sort of factors that might
that might influence how this popular
culture is getting made sure sure well I
can give you a little demographic
portrait of each one of the groups if if
that's of of interest and the oldest
group was which
one oh was the Reds yeah they were also
the
wealthiest and they were the group
within which a majority never graduated
from college so they're making the most
money but they weren't the most educated
they were most likely married they were
most likely living in rural areas um
most of them a majority of them
described themselves as as Born Again
72% were registered Republican they were
the least racially diverse group and
they were the only group where men
actually outnumbered women so absolutely
demographics Drive the kinds of
preferences that you saw up on the
screen for blues they were the youngest
group the most educated the most Urban
the most racially and religiously
diverse they were 79% Democrats 18%
registered Independents uh they were as
likely to describe themselves as
moderate as they were to say that they
were liberal or Progressive this was in
a separate part of the survey where we
asked them to
self-identify they were female um most
likely they were single or in a civil
union and most of them lived in the
center Great Lakes
Region okay one more uh
purples most haven't graduated from
college half identify as born again they
were most likely to be divorced widowed
or separated they were female majority
large city or suburbs they live in the
East the largest group of them uh
middle-aged and middle class more likely
to make less than 35k for household a
majority voted for Carrie in 2004 and
45% Democrat 24% Republican 31%
independent I gu maybe just a followup
question I maybe I don't know enough
about sort of statistics and and how
these sort of numbers play out but is
seems to me that they're like I don't
know sort of what what kinds of
consequences will those groupings have
because it seems like there sort of
little bits of there like a percentage
of a percentage of a percentage and sort
of how does that lead to any sort of
consensus well I guess what was
important to us was just trying to
figure out where the ideological divides
really are in this country before we we
could get to the work of the survey and
the research which was to figure out
whether there was any correlation
between politic iCal ideology and
entertainment preferences and we had no
idea where the fault lines were going to
be how many groups we were going to
discover how coherent they were whether
there were going to be coherent groups
at all but it turned out that there were
these three chunks and it was very
interesting to take a look at what each
one of those chunks really meant and the
the pressure on us from the Press was
really to figure out who the middle
group was because the way in which we
generally talk about politics in the
United States is between conservative
and liberal between Democrat and
Republican and we have a very vague
notion of what those people in between
might be like and who they are well it
turns out it's one and for Americans if
you're looking at our ideological index
and who are they what are they thinking
this is this was something that that we
wish to answer and we've done different
um uh subanalyses of the data in 2007 in
particular we did a big New York Times
magazine piece that was about female
model moderates um the moderate group
was the largest majority female of all
the three groups and we were very
curious about who they were as a
demographic and so that's the value of
it really is just trying to figure out
where the fracture lines are in this
country and ideologically how we sort of
cluster together in groups because just
looking at at party registration and
looking at the way people identify
themselves politically is much less
predictive actually of what their
ideological beliefs are and also lessed
icve of what their entertainment
preferences are we found if if you're
talking about a youthful cohort and what
they might be capable of in terms of
going forward they're right now tipping
over mainstream media culture um and
they're they're they're their their
influence is profound is self-producing
self-consuming self- editorializing
they're dictating terms uh uh going
forward so it is it you cannot under es
estimate what's going to happen in terms
of the political process because they
can move as a cohort and express needs
in a way that previous generations did
not imagine in the 60s if those guys had
a desktop like these kids uh uh uh had
and keep in mind keep in mind that
people uh uh your age now in addition to
all these amazing seemingly transparent
um uh networked behaviors now you vote
too so it's like if I'm running
nationally it's just like I'm going to
do what Obama did which is is is start
young and and and and and and work out
first because the amount of asymmetries
that the younger co-arts present in
media in media terms and and the thing
is is people say well how did brand
Obama get built without uh um wobbling
off course well it was selfcleaning up
and anytime he did you know that the the
the communication goes uh uh uh both
ways and boy if he really screws up in
the White House is he ever going to hear
about when he screwed up on NAFTA in the
campaign this huge actualized Network
jumped down his throat and it's it's
it's call and response it's not the
polarity goes uh uh both ways well
the Republican party has been trying to
pump up Bobby gendall as the the
Republican Obama we saw a good example
of his media skills this past week uh do
you think there are candidates who can
learn the lessons of
Obama uh they haven't found him yet I
mean that what what you know poor Bobby
Janelle I mean that was just terrible it
was just oh it it really was you know is
they're they don't have any ideas
they're exhausted um it reminds me of
the democratic part party 1976 you know
through 19 through the most recent
election and I don't know they certainly
don't seem to have any anybody um they
seem to have sort of retreads of of um
you know Democrats essentially um which
is what the Democratic party did um
remind people for about 20 years so I
don't see anybody in the
wings Sarah Palin is not you know I I I
I don't I think she might be charismatic
um but I don't think she has the sort of
Savvy and the ability to to work across
platforms she can only work in one way
which is a prepared speech and um and
perhaps in public speaking to an
audience which agrees with her but she's
not good across platform and Obama
really is good across platform um be
also interesting to see that you know if
the rest of the democratic party can
come on board to this I don't know if
they can his team certainly can but I'm
not sure the rest
can okay question over here my name's uh
Rohit sakua from the the uh a researcher
in the industrial performance center
here uh at MIT um I wanted to ask about
uh it seems like one of the things that
I keep hearing I you know sort of kept
hearing both you know during the um you
know pre-election as well as
postelection about Obama was wow it's so
nice to have an A per an inspiring
person in this office or so nice to have
an inspiring person running for this
office and so nice to have an inspiring
person then in the office and wanted to
I just just just wanted to to get your
sort of collective reactions as
to is that something that is happens to
be an important aspect of our culture
right now and is reflected in in in
other ways particularly in the you know
in terms of the type of entertainment
that people are that that people are are
are are um in you know looking for and
the type of entertainment that's popular
and I mean do we see that sort of
inspiration theme is this is this a sort
of temporal thing or does it happen to
is it something that we sort of see
throughout time and just so happens that
here's a guy who can actually really do
this um and curious if we see that sort
of inspiration theme reflected in other
in other areas of Pop
Culture I think it's very typical in
sports in particular where people have
these Idols you know they they have a
body like ours but they can do the most
amazing things with them it's it's just
incredibly inspiring and and you love it
when you find somebody who's different
enough to to somehow transcend what
seems like all the human fallibility
that that you're surrounded by and if
you two play the sport that you watch
them play on TV you're just in shock
like how do they do that and I think
that's the kind of feeling that a lot of
people have about Obama as well that
under all of this media pressure and con
an surveillance that he just doesn't
screw up very much it's like how did
that happen so I think it's very
important to have icons it's part of
what celebrity culture celebrates and it
can be aspirational for everyone but
it's I don't think it's in any way new
and I think it's certainly depends on on
people with huge Vats of talent and
those don't come around all the time
there's not many of them um I do think
that um let the economy stall for a
couple more months let them uh continue
to be unable to get a Comm Commerce
Secretary let his uh decisions in Iraq
come to Haun him and mainstream media
and the viral media will demonstrate his
feet of clay with enormous alacrity and
his exalted status will
dissipate like that and you you'll see a
clicking point I do think to your
question less not not getting into
whether US foreign policy has frittered
away enormous equities we had in the
world um which is sort of a tendentious
way of putting it but you know what I
mean just apart from that George Bush as
a hood
ornament on American culture people had
become uncomfortable with because he was
inarticulate because he his his great
sin in terms of world leadership
probably had less to do with was
significant strategic a and more to do
with the fact that the guy couldn't talk
couldn't communicate and didn't
represent us well as a people and there
was just a cultural reflex I think and I
think that was part of the Great hunger
of uh uh for Obama is and you saw people
very much purpled out who were totally
into him mostly because he could talk
mostly because he could commun they're
buying into the semiotics as opposed to
the practical decisions that he makes I
would AG I I would agree disagree with
David and I hope I'm right um but you
might be right I actually think that
like Ronald Reagan and like FDR that
actually the world can go to hell in a
hand basket and uh Barack Obama will
still have high approval ratings um I
think that he is at the top of his game
I think the sports metaphor is is is an
apt one it it is like watching an
athlete just at the top of his game he
has uniring instincts um he can pull
what should be a disaster the Jeremiah
right thing and turn it into a victory
he understands pacing the whole stimulus
package when the mainstream media did go
after him when the Republican noise
machine turned up he did what he had
always done his debates but on a longer
time scale he let it go let it go let it
go when the news cycle started to shift
he dominated the game for the last three
days I mean the guy is really really
good he also when in Iraq I mean in
Kuwait shooting basketball with the
troops he he made a Swiss shot from
outside the three-point line um you know
there's a republican conspiracy theory
that he's a Manchurian Candidate at that
moment I was thinking there might be
some Credence to that because no one can
do that with the whole world's media
watching
him okay over
here I'd like to provoke a little
further discussion about style and
Aesthetics and that I think that they
actually are political action not that
they precede it or that they surround it
but that the C of Aesthetics and style
is a political action and the thing that
has inspired me to think of that is the
increased awareness about lobbying and
the influence of lobbying on our elected
officials that what may appear as cold
rationality is in itself a style and
it's a style that it that tries to
disappear into political action that
political action is a certain way of
speaking and being and I actually
believe that George Bush appealed on a
on a certain level to this for eight
years that his speaking style did
represent many people and people are
very happy that the way that he kind of
challenged a certain coldness and
rationality with warmth and emotion and
Obama is actually taking the bush
project a little bit further in sense of
style and performance of
politics um if you're saying is there a
is there a politics actually embedded in
style and or Aesthetics I I I I think
yeah I think yes sorry that there isn't
that there isn't a uh an opposition
between style and politics but that
style is politics well I think that I
definitely don't think there's an
opposition between the two I think that
style definitely is politics and within
a certain way of appearing with the way
of speaking and so on so forth carries
with it a whole baggage a whole way of
seeing the world a way of arranging what
comes into our senses and what's left
out of our senses and so on so I
actually think that's why style has to
be thought of politically all the time
and we can't say you know one that we
don't do style we just do content
because of course that in itself is a
style so you always have have to be
thinking that over and over just just
quickly the the
um his ability wear uh Fame as a loose
garment which is something our culture
has come to ad admire is it gives him he
starts with style points I mean I was I
was in uh Denver and way way up uh in
the stadium and they did that drum roll
that they do at a big National
Convention the man is coming he's going
to be here over and over everybody comes
out and talks about this guy this guy
this guy and then when he comes out and
I'm there as a reporter I'm not there as
an American citizen but there's a
difference um uh but but after this big
drum roll the fact that that a black guy
comes walking out there
I was just like oh little windy up here
uh there's stuff flying into my eyes and
what I was reacting to is not Obama's
going to be a president it's no matter
what anybody has ever said about this
country we as a people regardless of
what he does can access the angel of our
better nature and to that extent his
ability to take that great weight and
not let him crush him not let it become
you know he he ran away from race
throughout but we all pinned so many
hopes on him and the fact that it didn't
bring him to his knees or that he didn't
go there rhetorically I just think is
the there was a Grace to it that is you
know putting away the three-pointer
Jordan at the top of his game it's like
how do he know that that that that we
were already as a people doing that work
and assigning that meeting and he didn't
need to pound that nail and that's I
think part of what he had
going I guess I I was just going to say
that there is so much substance in style
I think a lot of us would like to think
that style is just that surface it's the
bell and whistle it's it's somehow
divorced from what's what its packaging
that's never been the case it's always
historical it's always embedded in a
cultural context it communicates volumes
and people who are able to understand
the meaning of a style are the people
who can usually best communicate with an
audience and I think that's one thing
that Obama just has an amazing skill at
and I think it's one reason that so many
people has talked about his have talked
about his campaign in terms of brand
Obama because that's exactly what
branding is about it's it's it's
creating a space within a a retail
consumer Market that is owned by one
thing right it has an identity it has a
Content it has substance and and it's
ephemeral it's fake it's constructed
it's a few colors it's a swoosh it's
it's a whatever whatever it may be
composed of is beside the point it's the
meaning that it conjures that's really
important and so I think that's that's
one reason that it it's just completely
specious to try to claim that we can
somehow revive politics by taking the
entertainment out of it by taking the
style and the bells and whistles and and
the fun parties and the carnival it's
just not going to happen
okay time for one last
question um you talked a fair bit about
the role of of comedy in this past
election I wanted to um get your
thoughts a little bit on the role of
drama and particular uh some TV drama in
sort of perhaps laying the groundwork or
in helping to Define in people's minds a
sense of what's possible and what's
normal I'm thinking of things like on
The West Wing the character of Santos
who was specifically modeled on Obama
back when he was still a local
politician in
Illinois young Progressive nonwhite
candidate who actually gets elected
president um the role of of a program
like commanderin-chief with Gina Davis
uh becoming the president as a result of
having been selected as the running mate
for an elderly Maverick Republican
candidate
um the black president on
24 that these this sort of continuous
week after week set of
images that people are exposed to helps
to sort of lay the groundwork for so
that even though we've never actually
had a black president before the notion
of having a black president or a woman
president is not quite as jarring or as
surprising or as strange to people
because they've lived with it in that in
that medium over that length of time and
not just not just the the sort of
demographic factors but also uh The West
Wing at a time when people's opinions of
both the presidency and the Congress
were sort of in an all-time low of at
least reminding people of the notion
that it's at least theoretically
possible to have political leaders who
are both intelligent and well motivated
um to help uh keep people away from just
becoming totally cynical about politics
and reminding them of of what's possible
how how much of a role do you think
those kinds of images have played in
what's coming I think I think it's
immense I mean I I always joke that
westwing was you know the Exile the good
government in Exile um uh but I think
that it's dangerous to think and I'm not
saying it's wrong but dangerous to think
that it actually created a mindset which
was then going to be accepting of a
black president a thoughtful president
so on and so forth um I actually think
it also worked the other way which is
why that was successful why the
producers thought they could get away
with it why the money actually was given
to it and so and so forth had a lot to
do with a correct reading of the desires
of the American population I mean one of
the good things about living in a free
market capitalist Society is when things
don't tap into a public psyche they only
last one season and so if you got a
couple of Seasons under your belt you
know if I was a politician right now I'd
be watching house every single night
trying to figure out what's going on
there of course if we follow that logic
Steve it explains why Obama beat Clinton
since commander and chief didn't last
a actually I talked to the executive
producer of 24 who was a big Democrat
and he's like oh people are always
making fun of our show saying that it's
so conservative and it's so retrograde
he's like we helped get Obama elected he
said if I had been able to get the show
on the air um you know before the actor
strike he thinks Hillary would have won
because of cherry Jones portrait of a
president on 24 which is just now
running
so well I I agree with the basis of the
question which we as a culture been
doing these calisthenics for a long long
time and getting ready so well put okay
thank you very much uh if the audience
will join me in thanking the
[Applause]
panelists thank you very
much